so John if I'm a student studying
American history or US government what
why should I care well first there are
great stories the characters in American
history all the way through are
fascinating just human beings they they
would make great just movie characters
period heroes villains people who are
risen rise to courage when you know they
were otherwise pretty boring people look
at Abraham Lincoln for example he failed
miserably repeatedly repeatedly
repeatedly then he becomes the greatest
president and when he's almost at the
end of his well he doesn't know it's the
end of his life but later in life after
he's had his greatness he says I confess
that I was like a cork in a stream well
if you're a regular person and you think
my life feels good without a purpose you
can think well the greatest president in
America felt like his life was kind of
bouncing around and so that is an
incredibly human connection to greatness
and we all need connections to greatness
of whatever kind to inspire us because
the questions today that America faces
about freedom and liberty and what it
means to be an American and how the
power is distributed throughout our
governments and our lives that affect us
today we're discussed and talked about
and wrestled over all throughout
American history and it is a continuing
experiment and when Thomas Jefferson
wrote the Declaration of Independence he
said this new country that we're
creating has to constantly refresh each
new generation has to refresh their
contact with the original ideals that
the country was founded on otherwise the
country will fail and so it's not only
important to know what's going on around
us by studying history but it is
according to Thomas Jefferson your duty
to stay engaged with the ideas of
America so that those ideas don't get
lost in the kind of flurry and craziness
of a current moment